hey everyone Welcome to our cyber
security Journey today we delve into the
intricate world of network protection as
we explore the types of firewalls in an
era where digital threats Loom large
understanding that diverse forms of
firewall is crucial join us to unravel
the layers of Hardware software proxy
stateful inspection and Next Generation
fires discover how this guard s Shield
your digital realm from cyber intrusions
and now we'll move to the landscape of
firewalls and fortify your knowledge and
just a quick info for you if you want to
upskill yourself master cyber security
skills and land your dream job or grow
in your career then you must explore
simply learn's cohort of various cyber
Security Programs simply learn offers
various certification and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
MIT it kpur EC Council and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced hacking techniques
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
network security and over a dozen others
and that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top typ product and security
companies and academicians from top
universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into cyber security role as
a fresher or move on to a higher paying
job and profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box to
find a cyber security program that fits
your experience and areas of interest
and now let's start with the topic what
is a firewall a firewall serves as a
protective mechanism either in the form
of a device or software tasked with
monitoring Network traffic to identify
and thought potential threats and it's
primary function is to create a barrier
permitting harmless traffic while
blocking any potential harmful data and
the protective reach of a fireball is
adaptable catering to various scenarios
security teams leverage Fireballs to
safeguard networks from external sources
such as the internet second establish
protective parameters around internal
sub networks ensuring for instance that
HR personal cannot access systems
deserved for the devop team third
implement and traffic scanning on
individual devices like safeguarding a
BYOD laptop from incoming traffic and in
the client server model of network
security firewalls play a fundamental
role ensuring the safety of both
incoming and outgoing traffic however
vulnerabilities exist including success
ability to social engineering attacks
where malicious actors attempt to
exploit individuals by for example
stealing passwords for CEO fraud second
Insider threats that is posed by
individuals within the network
intentionally altering firewall settings
and then human errors such as employees
forgetting to activate the firewall or
disregarding important update
notifications so this was about the
firewall and now we'll see how does a
firewall work teams Implement a firewall
in line within a network to serve as a
barrier between external sources and the
producted systems administrator
establish chalk points where the
firewall scrutinizes all data packets
entering or leaving the network a packet
a formatted piece of data for the
internet transfer consists of a payload
the actual content and a header that is
information about the data sender and
recipiant and firewalls assess packets
using predefined rules to differentiate
between Banning and malicious traffic
these rules set govern how the firewall
examines and the first rule is source
and destination IP address and then
payload content and the packet protocols
example TC CP IP and then application
protocols HTTP tnet FTP DNS SSH and then
data patterns indicative of specific
cyber attacks the firewall blocks
packets that violate the rules directing
safe packets to their intended
destination and when a firewor restricts
traffic two options exist that is
silently discard the request or provide
an error reply to the sender both
options prevent harmful traffic from
entering the network the choice depends
on security preferences typically
security teams op to silently drop
request to minimize information exposure
if a potential hacker is testing the
firewall for vulnerabilities so this is
how does a firewall work and now we'll
see the types of firewall so we'll start
with the number one that is Packet
filtering firewall so packet filtering
Firs operate at Junction points
comparing each packet to established
criteria like IP address addresses and
port numbers while fast and cost
effective they lack broader context and
don't inspect packet payloads this makes
them suitable for basic security in
small or budget constraint organizations
and if we talk about the advantages the
number one is Filters traffic for the
entire network it is fast and efficient
and is inexpensive with minimum impact
and now talking about the disadvantages
it lacks broader context doesn't check
payloads and setup can be challenging
and now moving on to the next type of
firewall that is circuit level Gateway
so circuit level gateways monitor TCP
handshakes to determine the legitimacy
of network sessions while it is easy to
set up they should be used in
conjunction with other security
Technologies to prevent data leakage and
if we talk about its advantages it
processes requested transactions and it
is easy to set up and it requires low
cost and now talking about the
disadvantages it offers no protection
against data leakage no application
layer monitoring and it requires ongoing
updates and then coming to the next
firewall that is application Level
Gateway also known as proxy firewalls
application Level gateways filter
packets based on service and content
while providing fine grain security
controls they can impact Network
performance and are costly and now
talking about the advantages it examines
all Communications find gr security
controls and it protects user anonymity
and now talking about the disadvantages
it can inhibit Network performance and
it is costlier than some options and
doesn't work with all protocols so this
was about the third firewall that is
application Level Gateway and now moving
to the fourth firewall that is stateful
inspection firewall so stateful
inspection monitors the entire session
offering a high degree of control over
content while resource intensive it
provides substantive loging capabilities
and is effective against specific
attacks like doos and talking about the
advantages it monitors the entire
session and it high control over content
and substantive logging capabilities and
now talking about the disadvantages it
is resource intensive more expensive and
doesn't provide authentication and now
moving to the fifth firewall that is
next Generation firewall and Next
Generation firewall combines packet and
stateful inspection with deep packet
inspection and additional security
systems while offering optimal filtering
it requires integration with other
security systems and is costly and now
talking about the advantages it combines
DPI with other controls and it tracks
traffic from Layer Two to the
application layer and talking about the
disadvantages the complex integration
process and the costlier than other
types and choosing the right Fireball
depends on specific security needs with
larger Enterprises often using a
combination of these Technologies for a
layer defense so these were the types of
firewall and now we will see firewall
deployment options as the landscape of
it consumption models has evolved so to
have the methods for deploying security
measures firewalls today come in various
delivery methods including Hardware
Appliances software based Solutions and
services so first talking about Hardware
based firewalls a hardware based
firewalls operates as a dedicated
Appliance serving as a secure Gateway
between internal Network devices and
external entities unlike software based
Alternatives these self-contained
appliances do not draw on the processing
power or resources of host devices and
often referred to as network-based
firewalls these appliances are
particularly suitable for medium to
large organizations safeguarding
numerous devices however configuring and
managing Hardware based firewalls
demands a higher level of expertise
compared to their host-based
counterparts and now talking about
software based firewalls in contrast a
software based firewall also known as a
host firewall that runs on individual
servers or devices to provide protection
host firewall software must be installed
on each device utilizing some of the
host devices CPU and RAM resources
offering robust protection against
viruses and malicious content on a pre-
device basis software based firewalls
excel in the Discerning various programs
running on the host this granity enables
the filtering of inbound and outbound
traffic grated precise control over
communication permissions for different
programs and now talking about the third
deployment option that is cloud or
hosted firewalls many security service
providers deliver cloud-based firewalls
also termed firewall as a service this
hosted solution can monitor both
internal Network activities and On
Demand environments from third parties
cloud-based Fireballs entirely managed
by an mssp are advantageous for large
Enterprises or those with Disturbed
operations and security resource gaps
they also prove beneficial for smaller
organizations with limited staff and
expertise and this was all for this
tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful if you like the
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions you can drop them
in the comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here